good day everyone this is Jack Van Horn
from the university of southern
california and the big data to knowledge
training coordinating center and I'd
like to welcome everyone to the big data
to knowledge bd2k guide to the
fundamentals of data science webinar
today we're very fortunate to have dr.
gully burns from the information
Sciences Institute here at the
University of Southern California where
he'll be talking about the principles of
scientific knowledge engineering gully
burns as he is known to all of his
friends studied physics as an
undergraduate Imperial College in London
England until one day he had an epiphany
that he when he wanted to study how the
brain works and after completing his
doctorate at Oxford in 1997 he began
work at here at USC in the neuroanatomy
laboratory of Professor Larry Swanson
and began working building software
solutions such as neuro scholar and
newer arts neuroanatomical viewers
Mantooth in 2006 he moved kind of down
the streets to the information Sciences
Institute which is located in Marina del
Rey here on the west side of Los Angeles
to begin working in a little more de of
data science solutions and systems for
biomedical knowledge engineering one of
his main career goals is to transform
the way in which scientific knowledge is
utilized so that scientific discovery
becomes commonplace powerful and easy
and as we are going to begin hearing
from dr. burns here in a second I want
to ask everybody to just a little
reminder if you have any questions for
dr. burns throughout his presentation to
use the little question submission
system here in the GoToWebinar
interface there on probably on the right
side of your screen send those in and
during the last 10 minutes or so the
hour will I'll read those off to him and
you'll get a chance to get some of your
questions answered and I'm sure that
he'd be delighted to share his contact
information with you so should you have
any questions you can reach out to him
directly
so with that and without further ado
gulley thank you so much for taking the
time to present to us we're really
looking forward to it thanks again thank
you jack can everybody hear me well it
is my microphone working it seems
it's okay it is it's okay so um the
organization of the top today is broken
down into just basically five parts um I
may have too much material so I'll
probably start skipping stuff if we look
if it looks as though we're running
short of time but essentially I'm going
to try and just give a high-level
overview as to what scientific knowledge
engineering is really all about I'm
going to describe how this kind of works
currently in the community how people
build their knowledge systems and how
scientific databases and scientific
databases leverage the kind of
technology that science technology
engineering is all about and there but
but I also want to kind of highlight
some failings and questions about
general approach that people have
towards scientific knowledge engineering
and that most people when they think of
this discipline they think of knowledge
schemas and database schemas and that's
not the whole thing and then I'm just at
the end of the talk if we've got time
I'm going to talk a little bit about my
own ideas and about how I see the world
and strategies that I think can help
people who are trying to develop their
own systems you know how would you go
about starting the process of doing that
there are what are some important things
to think about when you're actually kind
of getting started with building a
system and then I wanted to start end
with a kind of high-level idea of just
presenting the kind of notion of
artificial scientific intelligence what
would it look like to have machines be
able to do science ok so um first
question is what is scientific knowledge
engineering and I wanted to kind of draw
on work by Michael Paul Rosenbloom who
wrote a book on the great scientific
domains and he actually was talking
about computing as a great scientific
domain in the same way that physical
sciences life sciences and social
sciences are and he kind of brought a
nice idea that says well you know you
need when we think of science we think
of social science physical science and
life science but computer science is a
valid kind of companion of these three
but it'll
so beautifully kind of complements them
and works together with them and the
definition that he has the computing is
one I really liked which simply says
that computing involves transformation
of information and when we're kind of
thinking about the evolution of we go
invariably to the great Jim Gray from
Microsoft who and if anybody's listening
is kind of want a good time they should
go to this website at the bottom to look
at some of the Jim's talks um he's uh he
was a luminary he's sadly none on the
with us but really fantastic work and
and his vision was that where as
thousands of years ago people would
perform empirical science so you
basically look at the stars and try and
explain them and then as we progressed
we would develop an analytical
approaches to kind of explaining things
you build analytical models to describe
the physics of the motion planets and
suchlike
and then more recently we've gotten into
computational science where all of a
sudden we have large-scale data sets and
a nice girl analytical models and we're
able to kind of generate computation on
these things and then the final the kind
of fourth paradigm as you talked about
is this notion of a science where you
have a lot of data a huge amount of data
big data captured by instruments or
generated by simulators and then
processed by high power high power tools
such as workflows and then can be placed
into a database a file a set of files or
a knowledge base and then the scientist
kind of interacts with the database on
those files in order to make predictions
and do that do that scientific work and
although you know I think this is a
beautiful representation of how things
have evolved we've certainly not gotten
rid of empirical science or analytical
so that's so it's worth thinking that
that even though we have evolved to
include these science in the process we
still need to think about empirical
science as a process that it's still
valid and important for certain things
um and so you know the point that I'm
making here is really the computing in
other words the the notion that the
transformation in information has
always been fundamental to the
scientific work whenever we've done
science in the past and the future we
are always going to have to have
structures that allow us to deal with
information transform it make sense of
it create it so before computers we had
scientific notebooks this is a page from
Darwin's field notebook we have
libraries literature we have mathematics
scientific theory classical statistics
all of these structures that help us
manipulate the information not on a
computer but nonetheless we're still
manipulating the information and now of
course we have large-scale data analysis
methods and simulation tools and
databases to help us with this process
but we shouldn't lose track of the idea
that that essentially computation
computing is kind of a fundamental
aspect of scientific work and has been
from the very start now just to kind of
dive into a little bit of philosophy if
you'll forgive me I wanted to introduce
the term reification and verification is
an interesting kind of idea that it's
basically it's when we try to think of
something abstract like a concept or an
idea as a material or concrete thing and
so what's interesting about this is that
we can think of apparatus so this is a
quote from a book called laboratory
light which is again great read it says
it's like we can think of apparatus as
rarefied theory so when another member
uses the NMR spectrometer for example to
check the purity of his compound he is
using spin theory and the outcome of
twenty years of basic physics research
so in other words the equipment and the
tools and the systems that we build
somehow kind of concretize abstract
scientific theory into a thing into
objects and those objects can be but you
are in the sense they can exist as
algorithms or computer programs that
live in a computer or they can be actual
physical apparatus like a cinema in a
mass spectrometer and so that's really
what this is about scientific knowledge
engineering is really about how do you
turn scientific knowledge into a
material or concrete thing and the
process of basically developing
information based systems to capture
store new scientific knowledge is
to this whole idea and and so you know
if you were to try and turn around and
boil down the the essence of what
scientific knowledge engineering is
really all about as a fundamental
challenge essentially we're asking the
question and said okay how do you build
a representation of scientific knowledge
in other words how do you write it down
how do you write the scientific
knowledge down into a structure that you
then would process and use with
computers and such and so so at that
that's the kind of high level
introduction to what scientific
knowledge engineering is in my mind and
so let's go into a little bit of how
this has shown up in computational
systems and things that we that we have
access to in the world so this is taken
from a paper which is a nice recent
review of scientific knowledge
engineering I recommend and all the way
through the talk I'll oh i'll be citing
information from other sources and
hopefully the review that and i will
i'll include references so that anyone
watching or reading this can see where
the information comes from by all means
please follow up on these links and and
and see if you can find things okay so
this de santos and travis oz in their
review described the kind of basic
fundamental idea of what in scientific
knowledge engineering is when we're
basically we're trying to build
computation under structure this is the
little block that you see on the right
hand side and we have scientists
engaging with the machine in two ways
first of all as a knowledge engineer in
other words you're basically trying to
build the underlying schema and
infrastructure of the system to kind of
make it work and then the scientist
himself interacts with the system to to
make inquiries to ask questions and to
get answers back and essentially that's
a good way of thinking about the the
core kind of role and approach the
scientific knowledge in knowledge
engineering has and and so at this point
it's kind of fun to think of the very
first biomedical database that was ever
created by humans in a real and concrete
way and this is of course the protein
databank or PDB and this originated
Cold Spring Harbor symposium 1972 and it
really camera came about because
technology for getting hold of molecular
structural data was becoming more and
more common and not only that but you
were able to actually display and
showcase yo computer programs being
created at that time very expensive and
impressive computer programs that were
able to render the images of these 3d
models and kind of display them for a
user to be able to see so that's a
revolutionary at the time and basically
what was what was interesting about this
too was that every single molecule
representation consisted of a bunch of
different 3d positions of atoms in 3d
space and up until this point no one had
any real concrete way of being able to
share the information within the
community so this a small group of
people all of whom were experts but they
need to be able to share data and so
from and so they basically organized
this transatlantic collaboration between
America and Great Britain and were able
to generate a tool with this that has
since 1971 has clearly really had an
impact in the world and and kind of has
stores very very significant information
it's and has embraced you know as really
motivated research at the highest
possible level and so this is a kind of
example of the kind of data the kind of
systems that we're talking about the
kind of things that we'll talk about now
we fast forward to 2017 there is a data
there is a publication called nuclear
nucleic acids research who every year
publish a single article oh sorry a
single issue that is devoted to all of
the molecular biology databases that you
can possibly think of in the world and
every year they basically receive papers
that describe these databases so each
paper is a full write-up of each
database in detail
and every year they as you can see they
add about 200 or 300 individual
individual databases to their repository
and since they've started this is now in
its 24th year but since they've started
the collection of databases that they
have amassed in terms of the
descriptions that they have consist of
15 categories 41 subcategories and
there's almost 2,000 s 1893 separate
databases listed in that collection and
it's worth noting that that a hundred
and ten of these systems that they
describe really are the highest possible
quality these are the so-called golden
set of databases that consist of the
kind of systems that pretty much all
biologists in the world use so things
like uniprot and IUD be these very very
high quality systems that are relied
upon within the community now it's worth
noting as well these are all molecular
scientific databases so it is a subset
of the systems of the types of systems
that are available and not only that but
they are the data that goes into these
databases tends to be more quantitative
and more tractable so even though it's
complicated even though there's a lot of
huge number of different dimensions of
this information that we need to track
and keep and and and moderate it's
actually I would I would say at some
level conceptually simple
excuse me conceptually simple and and
relatively easy to kind of capture
although of course it's still very
difficult but it is possible so the
state of the art of scientific databases
currently is that the kind of technology
that goes into generating these systems
or 1,893 of them is simply normal
data-driven web applications these are
databases that serve scientific
communities but the chances are the
technology that underlies them is kind
of similar to the types of websites that
you might see online
from any kind of industry or any kind of
company if anything they probably like
somewhat behind the curve in terms of
the sophistication of the the portal
interfaces and suchlike because we are
on scientific budgets and we have to get
money from the government to do this
rather than being able to hire being
able to command the kind of salaries
that Google and Facebook and these other
places are able to do but nonetheless
I'm the technology that underlies it
it's pretty standard and usually it's
something like a website with a
relational database back-end implemented
either in commercial system like Oracle
or mysql Postgres or anything like that
and so within this context what
scientific knowledge engineering really
is all about here is really how do you
design a database and how do you design
your web application and of course the
interesting challenge of that is that
rather than dealing with information
that you will find in facebook or or
business company or something like that
you actually have to deal with complex
scientific knowledge and that is itself
of course a challenge because scientific
knowledge is hard to understand it's
complicated it's multifaceted it has a
whole bunch of different things going
for it so much so essentially when we're
talking about these all these hundreds
and thousands of databases that exist
online essentially the question we have
to ask from a scientific knowledge
engineering standpoint is how do you
structure your data how do you
understand how it's together so first
question you have to ask is how should
your database schema describe it they
did you want to share the next question
that you'd have to ask is well where
does the data come from that you want to
put in your database
now this can come from the literature
and if you do derive it from the
scientific literature maybe you need to
hire people to read the literature in
other words these are called your bio
characters of cut curation staff who are
typically expert scientists themselves
and therefore are quite expensive to pay
in to maintain but nonetheless in order
to be able to actually preserve a path
decent database you'll you need to have
high quality high quality curated
information and or maybe your
maybe the database that you're working
with wants to stall a laboratory debase
data information that comes and that's
used that isn't published that is coming
off of machine somewhere and if that's
the case then you have to consider how
the data is formatted and also what
about metadata what about the contacts
of the infant of the data itself so if
you have a look let's say that you you
have an MRI database that you want to
want to store magnetic resonance imaging
from you I'm gonna have to actually you
can't just take all of the files that
you have put them online and say hey
everybody go at it how you take a look
at this you have to think about how the
data itself is structured and that
describes each individual person that
the scans are taken from and what
context is and how it all works that
isn't itself a very big challenge to in
fact that's probably the bigger
challenge than storing the original data
files now and of course it's like the
other question is how should your
website serve the data to your end-users
so you have a bunch of people who need
access to this information what's the
context of the access that they're
looking for how do you what kind of
functionality you provide all these
questions are actually scientific
knowledge engineering questions and
require you to think about and construct
the system pretty much in the same way
that you would do for any other web
application and any other web system um
but because it's scientific data you
have to think about these things in a
more deep white and then finally a
question that comes up that that's
important for people in the communities
how are you handling standardization of
your information so as you can see we
have 1893 databases they can't all use
different ways of describing what a
protein is they need to standardize the
approach that they're using and there
are as we'll get into it this is
actually probably one of the key
questions of scientific knowledge
engineering that we're going to cover
today but in fact it's it's it's
certainly not an easy could not a an
easy thing to kind of address so um so
the
and comes into a what stage in the
scientific process do you actually build
your system this diagram very quickly
kind of shows the various different
types of options that you have and there
are people who who build systems
straight from the laboratory and my
colleague Carl Kessel and si has built a
system called Arriba that does just this
and then perhaps you or you might want
to build a system that describes the
primary literature the literature that
that kind of captures the experimental
data at source
or maybe you want to build a database
that captures and summarizes the review
literature each one of these has a
various different set of parameters and
balances and checks that needs to happen
but it's interesting that the further
away you get from the laboratory the
more kind of well the less efficient the
system is and the more kind of you know
pre-chewed that the data can be it's
it's actually and and of course this
efficiency question is is pretty
important it seems silly for us to build
for us to spend huge amounts of money on
funding to scientists to do their work
publish papers and then have to spend
huge amounts of money on funding to
develop ways of extracting that
information from primary literature in
order to put into databases and which is
actually kind of what we're doing at the
moment so okay
so going back to standardization um this
is a comic from xkcd which I think
captures very well how this process
sadly does actually work the if you have
a situation where there are many
competing standards as is the case with
biomedical databases and all of these
various different approaches and if you
come into the situation say oh my god
there's 14 competing standards we need
to develop one universal standard that
covers everybody's use cases nobody
agrees with you and it's great and
typically what happens is your standard
becomes yet another example of a
competing standard that has to do
everything else now this is a this is a
pitfall that a lot of people are aware
of when we're trying desperately to kind
of work around but nonetheless as you'll
probably see quite soon this is still a
real problem that causes headaches for
scientists all the time now um so I just
wanted to talk very briefly about just
to give me kind of just to give
everybody on the call an idea of the
complexity of what a database typical
good-quality database schema would look
like so there's a system called shadow
or Chado I'm not sure if that's the
correct pronunciation which is a part of
the generic model organism database
project this is a database that's
implemented in Postgres SQL and
essentially it's designed to provide
standardized schema I'm sorry does earth
for genome for dynamic data associated
with generic model organisms now generic
model organisms organisms are things
like mice stress offer fruit flies cats
rats anything that any kind of standard
organism that people used to perform
experiments on and one of the kind of
goals of the the keymod project is to
standardize representational processing
of data from of different types from
these various different models in a
standard way the database itself is
actually quite big it's - consists of 18
struggled modules which subdivide the
tasks into 133 tables but it is used by
a relatively large number of databases
for different organisms so it's a you
can consider this to be a success on the
community and I just wanted to kind of
show you that the basic data structure
of these things is it can actually get
quite complicated so one of the tables
is this notion of a feature in the
database this is the kind of thing that
you might
that would be a general kind of a
general purpose phenotypic aspect of a
model organisms process or you know
something that's happening the model
organism that you want to keep track of
and if you draw out all data tables
associated with this including links to
the organism links to publications in
the pub table or locations of the
feature features this is actually quite
a fairly complicated and in-depth data
structure understanding this is is no
joke and of course if you look at in
fact the if you look at the structure of
the the database as a whole if you
looked at the scaled up for the whole
thing it would be vastly more
complicated than this and actually quite
difficult to understand
in addition what's important is that the
semantics and the structure of the
database is often kind of embedded in
the names of the actual terms that occur
so the cv term is a table for controlled
vocabulary term and the nature of the
semantics of the database are going to
depend very heavily on the types of
terms that go into that table so from a
scientific knowledge engineering point
of view of being able to understand and
build this kind of system you have the
underlying infrastructure of the of the
database tables you have to understand
if you're if you're working with gmod
databases but you also have to
understand the terminology and you have
to understand how the various different
terms linked together and linked to
existing database isn't all these things
so so this is just to kind of give you a
glimpse of the level of complexity
that's required on these various
different approaches and systems ok so
in order to kind of deal with this
notion of standardization across the
various different biomedical databases
that we we will encounter people in the
community of developers know I've
developed this notion or rather use the
notion of ontology and ontology is
construct from AI which is the best
definition I've come across is that by
Gruber in 1993 who says simply that it
is a specification of a
conceptualization so in other words the
way in which it's just a kind of a
representation a computational
representation of how concepts come
about and my colleague ed Hovey in 2005
wrote and the beautiful little chapter
and it describes five methods of
ontology construction and he breaks it
down from a high for a very high level
looking at the various different
communities of people who build ontology
within the computer science community
within the computer science community
and he describes them as five different
types so there's the Philosopher's the
cognitive scientists the linguists
computational reasoner's and the domain
specialists and what's interesting about
this is that typically and we'll go into
a little bit of how biomedical
ontologies are largely driven by
philosophers perspective currently but
there are other approaches that in based
upon which we'll won't touch on in
detail but there are other approaches
based derived from linguistic approaches
using just the meanings of words or
domain specialists such as biomedical
scientists who just need to kind of
represent the information in their in
their community as accurately in
strength orderly as possible and they
typically have a different approach and
philosophers but it's worth kind of
trying to consider all of them and I
think the thing that I wanted to leave
everybody on a call with if just as a
kind of a real concrete piece of advice
is that if anyone tells you that there's
one only one correct way of developing
ontology there's a standard methodology
that everybody uses that everybody
agrees on there are this thing doesn't
there there isn't such a thing there are
schools of thought and there are people
who address the question in a given way
but there's no one correct way um I
think that it would be a disservice to
anyone to try and suggest that that's
the only one ways is the best way and
cause different types of methodologies
trying to address this question run into
different pitfalls and problems so if
we're going to solve the problem
appropriately and powerfully we need to
use all the tools that are disposable
and kind of try and make sense of things
by leveraging any any and all approaches
the work and the provide us with actual
working tools okay so I wanted to talk
about a very important set of work from
the scientific community called the open
biomedical ontologies actually and they
call themselves the open foundry and
this is an attempt to organ standardize
ontology across all of biology and to
provide a kind of common framework for
building these knowledge representations
that everybody can use
in the same way this approach does
involve many important standard ontology
such as the gene ontology KB human
disease ontology there's one called the
ontology of biomedical investigation OB
it's it's significant and so there are a
bunch of these these various different
representations of knowledge that that
we you should be aware of and the
approach broadly broader uses the basic
form of ontology there's enough ontology
so and we'll describe very briefly what
basic formal ontology is all about just
to give you an idea of how it all is
structured and so over foundry lists 156
separate anthologies and this is very
much driven by community of philosophers
who have a kind of a clear idea as to
how they recommend see in the world and
part of the representation as you'll see
it tries to provide a kind of a global
catch-all type of view of the world of
the things that exist in the world so
that we can all kind of fit our various
different if you want to build a
representation of of things from domain
a then that should be able to fit into
the schema provided by the B of those
basic formal ontology if you want to
look at other things they should all fit
together
this is the kind of vision of the oboe
community and how they would like to see
it and this is a complicated diagram
don't panic I'm going to kind of walk
through it but this is the kind of high
level representation of how oboe foundry
ontology czar constructed the first the
top-level object is just an entities of
theme and then there are two types of
underlying then they basically split the
universe into two different types and
the continuance and occurrence and so
the idea is just like when you talk
about a thing and the basic way I'm not
going to go into too much detail about
how all these various different elements
work and I hope I get this correct
but occurence are things that that do
not physically exist in the world
continuance exist in the world as
physical objects so over here you see on
the left hand side there's an intrical
the material entity that could be a
supernova or a neutron star a cup or a
chair or a pen or a neuron right those
are all physical objects and essentially
the the way in which and the way in
which the BFO represents this is they
kind of they try and construct things
that exist in the world and they
distinguish between the different things
in order to kind of construct a kind of
global theory of how things are
organized excuse me so for example a
spatial region like your country of the
United States of America is a thing but
it's it's kind of defined by a spatial
region and it's not really a kind of the
landmass upon which it's built its kind
of the region that's contained within
anyway I'm getting off that popper topic
so you have continuance and you have our
currents and our currents and things
like processes so it these can be
thought of as flames because you can
describe them with words and they have
concept but they're not physical
entities in the same way that continue
itself so I probably just mangled out on
any
earning ontology justice on the caller
probably tearing their hair out but this
is I just wanted to kind of include this
as a significant part of the process of
working in biomedical in the biomedical
area because a lot of people use basic
formal ontology and it's it you had you
should go away and look at it look at
this website and become familiar with it
okay if you want to do work on this area
another significant tool another extinct
it approaches the bio portal which is
put together by Marc Goossens Gribble
Stanford and it's a lie a scale
knowledge on sorry ontology catalog so
it's a list of various different schema
describing various different domains of
knowledge and it contains 658 ontology
so sizable sizably more than the over
foundry on solid collection but they're
pretty non-standardized it's like anyone
who can submit something to by portal is
allowed to do so
and so these are usually they're not
kind of built with the same unifying
principles of and constraints of having
to conform to a standard complicated
difficult ontological design because as
you can as you might be aware the the if
you if you try to use the basic formal
ontology it's the kind of core
representation of your work you can fit
it into the schema of everything else
but but you also increase your overhead
in terms of being able to develop things
in the short term so by a portal
provides a nice catalog a large number
of different representations you can use
nuke again you can kind of like get into
very quickly without the overhead of
having to kind of fit it into this
complex higher-level schema and then
finally I wanted to talk about the fair
sharing org community and fair is a kind
of acronym that is being adopted widely
throughout the community to try and make
sure that we when we develop our systems
and our schema and knowledge bases and
all of these various different things we
so it stands for findable accessible
interoperable and reusable so and there
are a whole set of principles that are
published that one can find allied I
don't think I have a link here I'm
afraid on probably guys for that that
that allows you to that gives you a
checklist of things you need to do in
order to make your tools and systems
compatible with these principles and
Jack actually in a moment of brilliance
kind of suggested that we add the letter
e unfair for education well because I
think that's important because the the a
lot of these systems are quite
challenging to understand and the then
we're so busy a lot of the time kind of
dealing with computational interfaces
and systems and such like that we forget
that we need to actually make humans be
able to use these things another thing
about the fair sharing system is that
they talk about they talk about
standards but they also talk about kind
of standards winning the community
communities and policies so as a
repository describing a large number of
these various different and artifacts
and things that are worth looking at
this is a good place to look and this is
a good place to finds find interesting
material now no talk about knowledge
engineering and the web and everything
would be complete without talking at
least a little bit about linked open
data and the linked data cloud now this
is this is a diagram taken from the lod
dot cloud dotnet website and it's this
gancho an image of all of the various
different parts of the Semantic Web and
community that deals with various
different types of knowledge and the
important thing about this is that um so
if you just take a look at this diagram
as a whole and you'll notice that the
various different parts of the diagram
can be split up into different sections
in fact the life sciences forms probably
the largest individual sub community of
the linked data cloud and essentially
every dot in lists in this diagram every
circle describes a large-scale knowledge
resource a database if you like and the
promise of what the linked data can do
is that it allows you to actually
connect entities from one ontology with
from one knowledge base into other
knowledge knowledge bases using ontology
and so this is kind of inspiring if you
if you just kind of sit back and look at
this I mean um we're not going into the
details of any individual node but this
is this kind of gives you an idea of
what could be possible this is some
tough human knowledge that's available
in this format currently and if you
think about every individual database
smooth links together and how it could
be used to inform things that's actually
pretty cool of course the the the devil
is really in the details with this stuff
and you have to be able to understand
the schemas in these various
intelligence to be able to query them
effectively so it's not necessarily just
an easy task to pull information
necessarily out of this cloud whenever
you can but this is an expanding
research area and I think it's pretty
cool so other important stuff that I
don't have really have time to talk
about from the community are things like
well research objects these are this is
work by Carol Goebbels group and when
they define in Manchester and they
define well these encapsulated packages
of scientific knowledge so in the same
way the scientific publication kind of
draws together different elements into a
single place a research object provides
a semantic web based representation of
everything that you would need to know
about a data set including the data set
set itself provenance about whether
database data set came from maybe even a
workflow that general Wright said maybe
even the publication that was included
in these things so I'd recommend looking
at that as an important aspect and an
important important development the
field and then of course workflows are
only long-standing
piece of research in the community where
essentially you're basically putting
computational analysis together in order
to generate in order to be able to run
programs reproducibly and reliably and I
won't talk about that anymore so um
let's move on so this in the next part I
wanted to um we talked a lot about how
knowledge schemas and databases and the
underlying architecture of these systems
work but it's important to leave you
with the notion that schemas are not the
whole story especially when you're
dealing with the kind of representation
of of what knowledge is if you look at
this so this figure shows you a quick
it's kind of a high level view of eighty
thousand each dot represents an NIH
grant that was funded I think in 2010 I
could be wrong about the exact yeah
and each so there are 80,000 dots for
each grant that was funded by NIH all
broken down by color for each individual
agency that was each of the agencies
that were sorry each Institute that was
funding the work and it's important to
note that most of the databases that we
are talking about here probably occur up
here right as all of this kind of like
knowledge and stuff that's collected
into databases or in in areas where
molecular databases are well founded but
I don't know of many hematological
databases that are really constructed in
the same level of detail I don't I'm not
sure of any you know I do databases
constructing the same way there are
there are individual examples but
there's nothing like the kind of
coverage that you see in molecular
biology so um you know just having
schema and so the whole point is that
the variety of information that you need
to put into these systems is very large
and when you're kind of dealing with
knowledge you can't just talk about the
structure of the knowledge itself which
is in this diagram this is a kind of
three level representation of an
approach called common cats too
doing sighted modeling knowledge in a
knowledge engineering context and what's
interesting about this approaches they
have a whole methodology but try to
understand the context of the
information like what's the organization
how does the lab work that your that
your information is contained within
what is the task that the information is
trying to describe what are the people
what are the agents involved in in doing
the work and then you know the actual
representation the knowledge itself
occurs here that is required a
communication model to kind of figure
out okay how does that knowledge can how
is that knowledge used by the ape agents
trying to solve a problem that the
knowledge is useful for in communication
and all of these various different
elements combined together in the
overall representation of the design
model to give you the overall knowledge
representation and of course you know if
you're focused only on building ontology
then you're only talking about one small
piece of the puzzle there's only one
part of that the overall structure of
how you have to think about the model
and then another thing is over the tool
of the time is how do you evaluate
knowledge systems and and according to
this book by Edelman in riddle they
describe this kind of multi-layered
representation of the various different
types of evaluation you should think
about so and I'll just I'll just put
them all out you can see them now
and so this is broken down into four
different parts and first of all you
should try and understand so when you
evaluate a knowledge system you want to
evaluate the requirements sort of
validate the knowledge in the system
whether or not is didn't is if the way
in which the system deals with its
knowledge correct does it form does it
behave appropriately and very
importantly you know when you build a
website or you build a system that
people are going to use can you learn it
easily does it work well you have to
evaluate it according to that kind of
approach and then finally you know
performance evaluation you need to be
able to say whether or not your system
does what it's supposed to do well
and so these are all kind of evaluation
metrics that that are incredibly
important for people doing this doing
the work that I'm talking about but if
we're focused only on schema and
ontology and building these artifacts we
will miss this and so you know at the
end of the day it's important to kind of
it's probably more impactful to build
something that's less well-formed
ontologically and more useful for
scientists and that's borne out by a the
example of a gene ontology which is the
most widely used ontology in the world
today it's incredibly successful and
it's incredibly useful and important and
yet from a kind of classically
philosophically driven perspective it
doesn't really kind of solve it has it
makes lots of shortcuts and it takes any
kind of solves the problem in an ad hoc
way but it does so very well and part of
the reason why it's useful is because
people can understand and so I'm just
okay so I wanted to kind of jump to so
that can kind of concludes the kind of
advice-giving part of the of the talk
we've got about five minutes left as far
as I can see so let's getting through
the rest of it and here I wanted to talk
about some high-level ideas and kind of
future directions of what we should be
kind of thinking about and the work of
Thomas Kuhn is an interesting guide for
this process because Thomas Kuhn kind of
described the notion of scientific
paradigms and his kind of notion is that
is basically some accepted examples of
scientific practice a community and I
think of this is almost like a community
of various different elements which
includes laws theories applications
instrumentations social models of how
scientists work together with a specific
community and and the coherent tradition
of scientific research that constructs a
paradigm can we thought of as everything
that contributes to how that paradigm
works and in a Kuhn in his in seminal
work structure Scientific Revolution
talks about
normal science can doze this kind of big
cycle that works where you're going
along in normal science and then you
find something that's wrong you find an
anomaly and then you're normally so
great that perhaps you enter into crisis
and you're facing your paradigm is
shaken and you stop believing that you
know classic or like classical physics
works and you have to invent an entire
new approach you create quantum
mechanics you go through this to start
stift and then you have to kind of
figure out how this new paradigm works
within the context of neuroscience and
and it's important to know that this
very rarely happens the the kind of
normal scientific work that we do day to
day the kinds of earth-shattering
anomalies that form the basis of this
notion of Scientific Revolution very
rarely happens and instead we kind of
find ourselves very much in the normal
science process and where it's puzzle
solving now so within a and it's
important to note that but um there are
many different paradigms all kind of
over overlapping and and working
together that do not necessarily talk to
each other there's a kind of siloing
effect so if you work in molecular
biology and you work on let's say you
work on the macula biology of
schizophrenic schizophrenia for example
you'll look at pathways you'll look at
proteins you'll look at molecules but
you weren't necessary look at patients
you'll read the literature about
patients but you won't understand how it
works so in a way one can think of these
there are two paradigms kind of working
together in the coordinated way but they
don't necessarily communicate and part
of the work that I'm trying to do is to
figure out how these how more easily can
we get these paradigms to kind of work
together and so I'm kind of going off
the subject a little bit but um instead
of talking about this live scale
paradigm shift type of approach a better
model is treating scientific knowledge
evolution as a kind of abductive
arguments a choux process after 2 mins
paper work
I mean even better new model again by
the luminary Carol Goble is this notion
of knowledge terms and a knowledge turn
is a bit like is kind of described in in
this approach by this No
of the cycle of scientific investigation
the idea that that scientists start off
with scientific knowledge then in our
scientific questions they go from the
given a question they design experiments
they then execute experiment to get data
and they get knowledge and essentially
what we're trying to do is to provide a
framework to speed up the process of
going around this cycle I'm actually
running out of time so I'm going to just
quickly skim over this work this is
actually my contribution this is
something called knowledge engineering
from experimental design the idea is
that if you if one way of dealing with
knowledge should have in an in a
principled way is to draw out the
scientific protocol of whatever
experiment you're talking about
you can then trace the the provenance
back through the protocols indicated by
this red line from the kind of starting
time in the experiment and if you look
at these various different the idea is
that each square block is an entity
circle is a process and there they're
variously parameterised by these kind of
blocks animal number of kami opposition
such like if you trace back the protocol
in this way you then can build a
knowledge representation it's very
generic and works very well across
different methods and I'll go into it if
you're interested please look at this
paper from Russ 2011 I shouldn't and let
you know the idea is that kind of
take-home of this is that if you
approach the methodology of modeling
experiments using this kind of technique
you should be able to actually go beyond
the molecular biology experiments and
try and represent data from all sorts of
different things okay and then so
finally I'm just a kind of um I'll
finish on a kind of high note talking
about artificial science efficient
scientific intelligence because we talk
about AI all the time and I wanted to
highlight the work of Ross King who is
and one of my heroes he's awesome he
works in Manchester University and he's
built
he spent his career building robe
what's that that kind of go around the
cycle of scientific investigation
automatically without humans this is a
robot that can reason scientifically
constructed CERN theories it comes up
with its own hypotheses and it tests
those hypotheses through experiment it's
an absolute you know it's really really
interesting now the thing about this is
though it takes a lot of it's it's a
kind of a pre-programmed environment
robot can only ask one kind of question
it's programmed to look at it can't
think independently and so one kind of
big high-level idea that I have is could
we use educational methods that will
normally score scientific expertise in
us in a sub-discipline could we apply
that to computers and to our computers
computer systems and a colleague of ours
Michelle Trachtenberg
has put together a model of in this case
statistical literacy that rates people
on levels of beginner a functional skill
independent or master or expert and I
thought it'd be interesting you know why
don't we apply this to our computational
systems if we were to apply this to our
computational systems the very best
systems that we currently have would be
at this level of the beginners where
they basically remember facts you type
in a query and it tells you what you
bought they remembered what would it
take for us to develop computer systems
that are capable of higher levels of
reasoning and intelligence to do with
size and that's what I want to leave you
with as a final note so thanks to this
is just a list of people who have
inspired me and helped me and kind of
given terrific leadership and feedback
in my career and yeah thank you for your
attention
thank you so much Billy that was a
really great overview of a scientific
knowledge engineering and a number of
different key aspects that you need to
think about as you take this may be
yourselves or or or you're interacting
with systems and kind of getting us some
insight into how they're built one
question that I would like to just just
remind everybody that's if you do have
questions please send them in by the the
questions submission system so that
we'll be able to get them in front of
Bern's gully is people begin to consider
ontology z' and how then the thing about
knowledge or the knowledge domain in
which they want to begin modeling how do
you how do they begin and how do they
constrain it I mean it seems like you're
sort of throwing a dart in a dark room
throwing a dart at a dartboard hoping
that you hit someplace and then that's
the place that you begin and then things
start to spider outwards in terms of
what you're attempting to knowledge to
knowledge
model and then how do you stop it so
that it doesn't grow unconstrained and
it becomes this intractable problem how
do you kind of keep it real if that
makes any sense yeah okay great great
question Jack so I think a good starting
point is to look at actually go to the
big data you resource and look for
courses on data modeling generally now
and essentially there are there are tons
of courses that you can see about this
kind of thing that describe you know how
do you develop models in the UML
language for example the unified
modeling language which is which is used
by software engineers to develop things
like Java libraries and databases and
such like that gives you a kind of
high-level way of building schema that
gives you a kind of an overview that
it's widely used within the industry so
you know master's level computer
scientists can easily grasp that kind of
thing
um and then it's a short jump from
really taking technician of a
class-based or object-oriented schema
and converting that into an our ontology
consisting of classes and attributes and
elements right so and I think that you
know the a colleague of mine once said
no representation without implementation
as a kind of general rule you know
alluding to of course no taxation
without representation but I think that
that's a really good idea so don't try
and represent something that doesn't go
in your system at some point you know
this is you know don't try and represent
something that you don't have an example
for if you what you need to do whatever
you represent data on knowledge what
does it look like if you take a real
worked example and kind of flesh it out
and so my advice is that you basically
get a pen and paper and draw out
whatever full-scale example knowledge
that you're trying to work from and take
a look at that and make sure that that's
queryable and operable so you can
actually do stuff with it how does
knowledge engineering take into account
kind of counter examples if you will I'm
thinking of you know the is and has
relationships of these trade the tree
the classic tree diagrams its ontology
x' have and you know if you're modeling
something that's you know a human is you
know it has arms you know and but what
there are humans that don't have arms
and so how can one kind of keep track of
alternatives within an ontological
system that's still kind of you know
they're still human but this person was
born without arms or had them you know
they were lost in an accident or
something how does it handle that stuff
right well I think that that it's like
any piece of computational architecture
you have to the more complex and rigid
you make the more complex and rigid you
make it the less likely it is to be
useful and yet more easily the quick and
dirty you build it you'll be able to get
it up and running but they won't be able
to solve these into individual cases and
I think that again I go back to this
idea of what do you want this
representation of a person with arms for
is it a is it is it a patient intake is
it a representation you know what's the
actual use case that the knowledge is
going to be used for
and then then you can do an error
analysis and say okay look of all the
people we're going to see this is not an
important piece of information but and
of course that that isn't a kind of
universal solution that solves the
problem from a high complete kind of
point of view but it's still that's very
much my approach I haven't talked about
data modeling in us using statistical
models and neural networks in this in
this talk because we I was going to be
my next question is is summer yeah
patient ships be probabilistic for
example um or you know I don't know it
was gonna ask you about that yeah that's
a whole that isn't that's another talk
um I think that there's you know when
we're talking about biomedical databases
as you can see right the databases that
people use in the scientific community
are still mostly working with knowledge
at the level of tables and and
attributes and and schema right but but
there is a big push to try and build
these systems that are capable of
reasoning over complex data spaces that
you see in the real world like the space
of all microscope images taken from
brain tissue if you wanna sit down and
you kind of like look at those brain
images and you try and build the
taxonomy and is a taxonomy of the
different types of brain images you will
not succeed right but if you train a
classifier quare people are training
classifiers who are able to leverage you
are able to classify tumors or or
various different kind of growths in the
brain and such like but we'll also and
and we'll also be able to kind of yeah
do do other interesting things with data
so so neural networks is very much a
very much a kind of an important and
exciting
framework for things to kind of move
forward with there just in general I
think that's a an observation that you
see in literature there's the this is
definitely a kind of the trend of one of
the most exciting trends that I've seen
in terms of where this is going to go
it's not obvious exactly how it fits in
with the existing symbolic
representation of things and as a
general open-ended question but you know
that's I think that's a very exciting
way in which this well that may very
well be the future well we've reached
the top of the hour everyone thank you
so much for taking part in the big data
to knowledge guide to the fundamentals
of data science thank you to gully burns
for sharing his thoughts on scientific
knowledge engineering with us we really
appreciate it gully and keep your eyes
peeled in your email for further
announcements about future guide to the
fundamentals of data science webinars
and until then everyone have a great
weekend and we look forward to seeing
you again soon thank you so much and
thank you going thank you